だからこれは今は大丈夫ですそれは速いです
そしてそれはとても良い公開です
そしてそのビデオが来たらそれはすぐに現れるはず
ですええ
大丈夫私たちは
大丈夫です私たちは私たちだけ
が面白いだろうと
思います
私たちはそこにいないだけでなく、
フーディーも切り替えましたええええええ
私はこれに気づいていませんでし
た私たちはウィンドウでこのストリームのように開く必要があると思い
ますええこんにちはみんなええと
幸せええと感謝祭 道元の下でYouTubeで行っ
た最初のビデオだけでなく、
おそらく約1年半前の別のビデオにも参加していた友人のジェイソンは、
この時点
で私が日本語を話すのは私だけでした
ビデオええ、私たちはそのビデオも一緒にやりました、
そして
ええと、私たちは同じ
非常に小さな武道のトリックの世界の一部だった
ので
、当時から間接的にもお互いを知っているので、
ええと、それはちょうどだと思いました
ええと感謝祭のstrのように楽しくする ええと、ええと、
ただ冷やしてください
ええ、町でジェイソンと一緒に冷やしてください。
かなりの数の人々が
幸せな感謝祭で滴り始めているようです。彼ら
は日本に七面鳥を持ってい
ます
か？ ええと、私が
ここオイタに住んでいたとき
、ええと
、ええと、私は何をしましたか？
七面鳥はこの大きなもののように多分この
大きなええのように彼らはでキッチンを借りるでしょう
そして料理学校のようなこれらの1つのように
彼らは料理学校のキッチン全体の1つを借りるのと同じように
そして私たちはちょうど巨大な
感謝祭の饗宴をしました
6つの調理ステーションがあるので、誰もが同時に
自分の料理を作っ
てテーブルに持っていくことができるので、
それはクレイジー
でした。 ええと、クリスマスのkfcのように、
去年は2年前のことでしたが、実際には長続きしませ
んでした。 ひどく渋谷から遠く離れていますが、
十分に遠い
ので、チキンを事前注文しようとしていませんでした。洞窟からチキンを入手するために、ラッシュチキンの時間にそこに走る必要があります。
正直言って、kfcのチキンは嘘をつきません。
あまりにも
きれい
すぎて本当にそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
あなたが取るすべてのかみ傷のようなその不健康私はそうそうなりたいと思った
これはダメージを与え
ている
kfcのことを感じているの
は、カラゲのような日本人のようなクリーナーが好き
だったからです。数年ぶりにkfcに行ったのは、
日本がどこにもない真っ只中のジェットプログラムで3年間過ごした後の
ことです。 ええ、kfcではありませんでした ディ
はフライドチキンの唐揚げを和風のように食べていたので、ベップに引っ越してチキンを食べました。
これはとてもクレイジーな感じでした
[笑い]でも
、それだけで
は十分ではありません。
冷蔵庫で揚げるために他のものを揚げ始める前にフライヤーを揚げる場所のように、
すべての人がどうなっているのかは理に
かなっています
チャットで私はちょっと
あなたがどう
なっているのかわからない人のために
あなたがあなたを知らないように与えたいのです
か 一緒に
、
あなたがオンラインで
やっていることのように、そしてええ、あなたが日本でやっていることのように、短い自己紹介の話をしたいですか？
交換留学生として、私は
ちょうど決めました なぜここに住んでいないので、私は
現在ゲーム会社で働いている
ので、私はuhkoeまたはkoitechmoで働い
ています。 たくさんの友達私は
irlの領域で物事のけいれん側でたくさんの友達を作っています
が、ええと、
この男は
、フライドチキンが絶対にどうあるべきかを知っているように聞こえます。
ええええ
大丈夫大丈夫私たちはそうだと思いますええ私たちは
F爆弾
を楽しいものに制限するつもり
です 頭脳
そうそうそうそうそう私は
ビデオゲームストリームのようにたくさん
やっています。そこでは、
ゲームデザインの専門知識を、
時々
ゲームをプレイするようにプレイしているゲームのいくつかに取り入れています。
アニメーションがどのように機能するかを分析
したり、生姜のインパクトでやったアニメーションのことを好きになったりします。
おもしろい面白い
アニメーションの
いくつ
かは壊れている
面白い 今あなたのためのキャラクター
ええと、あなたはこれについて話す権限を持っています。
なぜなら、これは実際に
あなたが好きなあなたの仕事のためにあなた
がしていること
だからです。
モーションデザイン
のようなもので、キャラクターのパンチ
キックがどのように実行されるのか
、それらのデザインドキュメントを送信
し、cgから取得するたびにどのように実行されるのかというようなものです。 それらを見て、
これは正しいか、
バランスが正しくないか、この手の
位置が奇妙であることがわかっているので
、ちょっとした調整がそこにあることを確認します
が、ええ、メインを見ました
夏のノエル 彼らの点で
は、ノエルはとにかく頑丈なメイドですが、
そうです、最初にあなたのために台無しにするのは
大丈夫ですええと、私は先に進ん
であなたのために彼女を台無しにする
つもりです ユーラまたは彼女は
実際にバナーで自由です私が何を話しているのか知っていますか
私がプレイしていなくても
大丈夫ええ
申し訳ありませ
ん 彼女の足を見て
ください私は攻撃がどのように進むかを正確に忘れています
が、彼女がこの方法で1つの攻撃を終了するよう
に、次の攻撃の開始は混乱
し、反対側を前方に開始しました
。 実際
にそれらを見ると、彼女のキャラクター全体が表示されます。
私が行くのは
、まるで5つ星のようです
。umxiang lingは
、彼女のアニメーションに関する多くのことのように、絶対にひどく壊れています。
フレームそれは
ばかげて
いるええと
、それから
本当に本当に本当に良いアニメーションが面白いものがいくつかある
ので、ええ、それは本当に奇妙
です、彼らはチームのさまざまな人々のようにほとんど行われているようで
、彼らは
ちょうど十分ではないようなものです
それをチェックする時間はそれを送信し
ますが、ええと、それは
巨大なサイドトラックでしたが、ええ
、私は私のストリームでビデオゲームをたくさんプレイします
、そしてええと、最近
私は私が明日を意味するように
しようとしました 山でサルを見に行くええええええ
私たちがつながった主な
理由は、
ジェイソンが私が学生リクルーターとして働いていたベップアプの大学の学校の学生だった
から
です。  34あなたは3333ですので、年齢は非常に似てい
ますが、さまざまな理由でさまざまな時期に大学を始めました。
そこで接続し、トリックで
接続しました。ビデオゲームで接続
しました。 オンラインのもの
と
私
はapuからyoutubesphereに切り替えようとし
ましたが、ジェイソン
はチーム忍者でtoeicで働いていました。
私より少し少ない少し少ない
ペルソナ5ロワイヤルをプレイしたことがあると思います
私も持っていません私も持っていません
正直に言ってすべてのペルソナが私のリストにあります
そのような戦いのためのペルソナは
、キャラクターだけへの私の最初の進出でした
ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええ、私は
ええと、適切なペルソナゲームの
ようにプレイしたいのです。 ええええええええ
あなたが会ったことを感謝しますええ
と彼は死んでいるか生きているの作成者であり、彼
は忍者龍剣伝を再起動しまし
た私は忍者龍剣伝を持って
います 私は 私が来たとき、
彼はもうそこで働いていません。そうそう、彼
は今自分の会社を持っ
ています。
会社ええ、私は
鍋などをかき混ぜないようにしないことを意味します
が、もちろん、公開
されていた
ものはたくさんあり、公開され
ていなかったものはたくさんありますが
、私はそうではありません ええ一言言うつもり
ですええ私は私の仕事が好きだ
からええええ
私は大丈夫です
ハニー
あなたはジェットプログラムをお勧めしますかそれ
はドアに足を踏み入れるのに良い
です 以前のビデオですが、多く
の人
が日本に行きたいという理由だけで日本で英語を教えたいと言っ
ていますが、彼らは
実際に日本で何をしたいのかわからず
、場合によっては
私自身が
あなたを含めて何が起こるか 日本で英語を教える
ことは、likのためにそれをした後に実現します 2
年間、多くの時間を無駄にし
ているのですが、それはあなたが情熱を注いでいることではありません。
クリックするのに時間がかかりすぎると、他の人があなた
の悪い状況に陥る可能性があり
ます。 年齢は、
あなたが少し日本人を知っているかもしれない
あなたと比較して、能力と知識の仕事の経験の点でより競争力のある競争力のある種類の
スキルを持っています。 小中学校の教科書の
ような3年生のようにテープレコーダーとして文章を読むのと同じように、
それは私がデロイットなどを知らないように2年ほど過ごした他の人のように競争力
がない
ので
、私は 多くの人に与えるのが好き
ですまた、ジェットプログラムは
あなたの足をドアに入れるのに素晴らしいです
そしてそれはあなたが日本にいる間にあなた
の側であなたのスキルセットを開発するのに取り組むのに十分な時間を与えます
o
繰り返しに
なりますが、私が言いたいのは、日本に来られなかったら、夢の仕事はどうなるかということです。
ここに来られなかっ
たら、夢の夢の仕事は
大丈夫です。
さて、それはあなたが日本でやるべきこと
ですええ
、それは実際に私のバックアップ計画になるのはおかしいです。
なぜなら、私は実際に
小学校中学校の先生のように先生
になることに本当に近かったので、
特に外国人の先生とは、あまり教えていないという話を聞いたことがあり
ます。あの
ように、ここに別の
発音があります。
ええと、iiはすでに
そこに準備されていることを知っています。 たくさんのダウン
タイムがあるので、私はそのダウンタイムを使って
、ガンホーの
ように、
ゲームのデザイン
や、その時間を効率的に使うことを知ってもらうために必要なだけの日本人のように勉強するつもりでした。
確かにy これも経験し
たことがあり
ますが、私自身も含めた多くの人が
少し遅すぎることに気づいたようです。
たとえあなたがネイティブではなくネイティブのように立ち上がったとしても、
日本語の流暢さの点で競争力のあるレベルは大丈夫のようです
あなたはついに、国内の
他のすべての日本人
があなたよりもはるかに優れているだけであり、彼らがすべての時間を費やし
ていないという理由だけで別のスキルを持っているという点に
います。
日本語が
話せるのは、日本語が話せない場合に比べて大きなプラス
ですが、日本語が話せるからと
いって、日本社会でとても満足している仕事に就けるとは限りません。
つまり、他のスキルを理解しなければならないように
、他に何をテーブルに持っていくことができるかを理解する必要が
あります。その上でさえ、
あなたの日本人が
スーパーバンガーのような上司であるとし
ましょう。 置く
あなたを特別なものにしているのは、
流暢な他の言語を話すことですええええええ
それは彼らが必要としているものだ
からです
彼らにあなたは
別の言語を話すことができますええそして私は
実際に友達に翻訳のようなことを経験させましたが
、彼らは
ネイティブの英語を話す人であり、彼らは
会社に行き、会社は
彼らにそれを確認するためだけにテストをします
彼らは実際に英語を話せる
ので、彼らは会社に行って
、こういう感じでした
。
もちろん、私たちは完璧です。
誰かが
私に何かを言ってくれました。ジェットプログラムで3年目です。
文字通り他にアンビがないので、おそらく5年間滞在します。
私は教える
ことを楽しんでいます。あなたが教えることを楽しんでいるなら、
それは
素晴らしいことです。私は
長期
的に教えたいとは思っていませんでした。
その
意味で、私はできるだけ早くジェットプログラムをやめたいと思っていました
が
、
私がレッスンを読んだことがほとんどないことを知るまで、YouTubeでうまくいくことができませんでした。
クリエイティブライティングのような用語
ええ、ええ、私は実際に
教えることを本当に楽しんでいます。それ
は、私が実際に教えていないときに教えるという考えが好きではないという
ことです。  「実際
に主題を取得していますが、大学時代に
えいかいわうんをやっていたときはとても幸運だった
ように、このクラス
がこのレッスンを受けられないように真剣にできるので、私はそれが大好きでした。
すべてb 一日中、
みんながこのレッスンを知っているところに行きます。私は
実際に私のスタイルで教えることができ
ます。私のスタイルは、冗談を言ったり、楽しんだりする
ようなものです。 教えたかったのですが、
それが問題なので、そうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
そうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
そうそう 日本にとって、私の人生は最初の6か月かそこらですり減る
完璧なものになるでしょう。
なぜなら、
あなたはまだ生き続けなければ
なら
ないからです。
それについては大丈夫です私は
日本に行くつもりです私は
あなたが日本に行くつもりのように日本語を学ぶつもりですあなたはまだ
歯を磨く
必要があるでしょうあなたはまだおそらくうんざりする必要があるでしょう
あなたがフィンする必要があるいくつかのポイント
家を手に入れて電話を借りる必要がある食料品
ええ、
あなたはボーイフレンドのようになりたいのか、
ガールフレンドのようになりたいのか、人生がたくさんあるように一般の人々と話したいのか
あなたとあなたが日本にいる方法と同じよう
にええええええそれはただのラッドウィンプとマウントフジだけではありません
彼
を日本に落としましたが、私は
主に独学の
ゲームデザインのような歴史がありましたが、
私はアメリカにいる間にいくつかのインターンシップも行いました
、そして私はコンピュータサイエンス専攻として始めましたが、
私は個人的にメインと言います
私の仕事を得た主なことは、
インタビューなどを行っていたときです。それは、私が武道
の歴史を持っていると言ったときです。私
だけでなく
、もちろんあなたは私が傷ついたことを知っています
私がpuできるように死者または生命プロジェクトにアップ
私の多くは武道の使用法などの知識を知っていますが、私も
彼らにまっすぐに言いました私は
私が
願いのようなドルのようなものを持っていた場合、
私はスーパーが欲しいようなものです パワー私たちは家にスーパーパワーを持ってい
ます私は家にいるスーパーのように
私はそれらを見るだけでたくさんの体の動きをコピーすることができます
犬かきができなかったような面白い
泳ぎ方最初に泳ぎ方を学んだのは
、遊んでいて横向きに泳いで
いるからです。
それが私が泳ぐ
ことを学んだ方法であり、その後私はオリンピックを見てより速く泳ぐ方法を学びまし
た彼らがこれをしているとき彼らが
水を叩いていないように見たい
ので 後ろ向きええええええそして私
は 私の場合
、あなたのような能力が共有している
私はそうです私は共有のウィッシュバージョンを持ってい
ます
アニメーションのようにダンスを好きになる
方法を自分で学んだよう
にええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ そんなことをし
ましょう。
鏡で30分ほど練習してバスルームに出くわし
ました。7歳のときにいつでも
この眉
を
上げる
ことができたので、この眉を上げる方法を学びました。 どちらも無意味な
スキル
です
が、体の筋肉がどのように機能するかを知っているように、私はかなり上手い
ので、私はある種のものを見ることができます。
それを見て、私はちょうどそのことについて何かがオフになっ
ているようです私を待ってください
もう一度わかります。
それはとても面白い
と思います。ええ、私
たちは両方ともトリックのバックグラウンドから来ている
という
ことです。あなたが私に言ったことの1つは
、バタフライツイストを初めて着陸させたときのようなものだったことを覚えています。
偶然のよう
に、コンボの真ん中に投げたようなもので、
着陸したのと同じように、着陸する
のに1か月
ほどかかったので、実際に
才能のようなスキルはかなり
ええええiiそれは楽しかったですああ私たちはスーパー
チャットをし
ました日本を愛してくれてありがとう
仕事でどれくらいの日本語を使っていますか
アメリカの恋鉄拳のように話していたのでなければ、大丈夫です
が、私のような私のドキュメントはすべて、
日本語のようにたくさんのモーションのことを学ばなければなりませ
んでした。
そこに何があったのか
私が何かを説明することを具体的に学んだのと同じように
、私は
ここで大丈夫だったので、それをcgチームに送りました、
そして私たちは
彼らが私がこれを自分で調べなければならなかったようです
日本語の体の部分は
実際には正しく使われていないので
、iiが何かをしたように、
それが何であるかを正確に忘れていましたが、私は
それの専門用語を見つけました、そして私は大丈夫のようでした
私はそれを送りました、そして彼ら
はこの言葉が何であるかの
ようですが、ええ、
基本的に最近の私のプロジェクトは
少しうーんですので、私がやったように私はええと
で
はなく、neo2のローカリゼーションのほんの少しを助け
ました ええと、それは私のいとこ
がそのゲームを愛しているので、それはああ
、私たちがオタクをしているストリームの前に
面白い
です。
とものと私たちは
オタクでした ああ、すごい素晴らしいゲームのほぼすべてについて
誰かが以前に尋ねた
、彼らは
あなたの後ろにあるファイナルファンタジーviiええ
、これまでの私のお気に入りのゲームのオリジナルであるファイナルファンタジー
vii、そして誰かが
攻殻機動隊についてコメントした
ので、 ウッドブロックペインティング
とええ、それは
ロシア人の
ウミディオソンです。日本に住んでいるロシア人のイラストレーター
は、アニメのネットフリックスの
ようなシェルの最近の幽霊のキャラクターデザインを先導した
と思います。
ある種の日本の文化財団とのコラボレーションのようなもので、
彼らは
素晴らしい
日本のウキヨのようなアーティスト
とチームを組んで、これを信じられないほど素晴らしいもの
にしました。
日本で一生懸命働いている外国人がゼロのように
なり、業界のリーダーのようになっていくことを象徴しているように、これについてのすべてが大好きです
日本人と一緒
に素晴らしい色と同じように美しい素晴らしいアートを作るために
ええ
私はこのグリルを見たらすぐにこれが大好きです
ええええええええ
真剣に
今
これがやって来ました
日本語で
データサイエンスに移行するために必要な
日本語の量を理解しようとしています。
基本的には、ほとんどの企業にあなたを見てもらうために、基本的に始めて
ください。
多くの企業
は、何かをするように指示
できること、1つのテキストまたは1つの電話のいずれかで指示できること
、そしてそれを
十分に理解してそれを実行できることを知っておく必要があるためです。 ほんとうに
そういうことになるのですが、あなたのことを好きにしようとする人が
いるので、差別があるように悲鳴を上げたり、
「ねえ、私にその緑色の箱を手に入れてくれませんか」と言ったら、
そこに座って
ええと、あなたは
私のために仕事をすることができないので、
ええ、私はそれについてもっと本当の速さで同意することができませんでしたのような青い球
は今それは
ほぼ完全にトピックから外れてい
ますが、私のような小さな三角形
は幽霊と細胞のようなものです
三角形ですが、何らかの理由で
私に完璧なダーク
を思い出させましたええええええええ彼らは私にデータダインのシンボルを思い出させました私は長い間
データダインについて考えさえしていませ
んでした
ジョアンナ・ダークが参加していたキャリントン・インスティテュート
、そしてデータダイン
それは悪者だったと言い
たい 第二に、みんなが
その向こう側のようで、
あなたがそれを手に入れた向こう側の神のようで、それはロックオンのようなゲームオーバーの
ようで、壁を撃ち抜く
人の人々はこれを
最高のシューティングゲームの
ように言い続けます th インク
ゴールデンは最高のシューティングゲーム
です。パーフェクトダークは最高の
シューティングゲームです。パーフェクトダークは文字通り
ゴールデンアイ1.5
です。外国人が日本で声優になることは可能だと誰かが
言ったのは面白いです。
これに対する答え
は、ジェイソンが実際にかなりの量の
声を出したような意味での答えですええ、私はメインの
声でもあります私はシステムの声であり、死んでいるか生きています6
準備をしてください
私の声
はリバーブの束に投げ込まれますええと彼らはまた
私の声をええと維持したと思います
概念実証のように、そして最後に彼ら
はここで大丈夫だったようでした私は実際に
私が持っていたようなものを申し訳ありませんでした
私もこれを言いたいです
後で私がレベルを言った方法 ええ、
究極の同盟のため
に、私は私の脳のどこにいるのか、
レベルアップのように、私の
脳
は病気から獣王記に変わったのか
、セガジェネシスのような
獣王記を覚えていますか？ あなたの墓
とあなたがパワーアップするたびに
あなたが知っているように彼はただより多くのバフ
を得るが、彼がパワーアップするにつれて彼は
レベルアップのようであり、どういうわけか
ちょうど休憩中にあったように私の脳は
あなたであり、それは生きている 6つのジェイソンそれは
とても素晴らしいですええそれはジェイソンです
だから私はあなたの商品を日本に入れることができますああ
ええあなたは
ここに着くのに少し時間がかかるでしょうが私たちは両方とも日本にいます
私は彼の他のフーディーも家にい
ます
ええ
、あなたがそれを見なかったなら、今、黒い金曜日の割引のようなものがありますえ
えと、このビデオの説明にリンクされているので、誰かが興味を持っているなら、ええと、私は考えるべきでした そのような
ものもそうですが、それから eはまた
、実際にチャットで誰かがこれについて言及している外国人のようなものですが、実際には
日本語の声のように振る舞う日本の声のように振る舞っています
が、彼らは日本人ではありませ
ん それは
まったく別のレベルですええ、私は
実際にジョーイがそのいくつかを行ったと思いますええ
と私は私の父がそのゲームをプレイしたときに
私がとても積極的に3歳だったのでそれはドープええ変更されたと信じ
ています
耳をふさいで部屋を使い果たしたように、すべてのミツバチがオンになるのを聞いて、
あなたを笑わせてください
。
良い
チャンネルええと
、彼らが私が存在することを知っていると決めたら、
私はそれに反対して
いません。
どうしたの  でも
ねえええあなたは歴史を見てきましたああいや私は
絶対にこれを見ましたええそれは陽気です
ええ私たちは彼のチャンネルにあったのでそれほど長くないコラボレーションをしました
彼はサクサクのウィーブのようで、クリンジの
ように逮捕されたような
ものでした。私はそれについて報告するようなものでした。
年と私は4歳だったでしょう
[笑い]
あなたはまだ別府に住んでいるので、私は別府に住んでいます
ジェイソンは東京に住んで
います 超音速youtube.com
超音速
そしてまたあなたはけいれんにもっと積極的ですか
私はけいれんにもっと積極的です
私のけいれんは超音速540なのでファイブ
フォーゼロそれはジャムするのと同じこと
です mしようとしている私は詐欺しようとしている
ビデオの作成に戻るか、
少なくともyoutubeで関連するビデオのようになります
が
、ストリーミングしようとしています
が、3回言うつもりでした
が、週に3回は、
アイスクリームを通して同じ
です。
それはチャウダーと呼ばれる漫画でしたが、
それは奇妙な漫画ですが
、アイスクリームの代わりに3つのクリームが
あり、私はいつもそれが面白いと思っていました
私はあなたの髪に誰もコメントしていないことに
驚いています
青い紐のように見えないええ
、あなたは通常アフロを持っているので、私の頭をカメラに向ける方法を理解しているようです
が、私は先週の日曜日にこれをやったばかりな
ので、ええ、それは本当に良さそうですあなた
は見つけるのに問題がありましたか
東京の誰かがそれをすることができましたええと誰もい
ませんそうです
私は調査をしました私は場所を見つけました
そしてそれから私は場所を見つけましたそして
私がそこで髪を整えるたび
に
彼らは別の女の子のようでした
現れるので、tのように これをやった女の子は
私が好きだった私は所有者に私
が次回彼女を要求しているようだったことを知らせ
ました彼女は
時々人々があなたの髪を編んだときのように良い仕事をしたので
上唇
を髪の毛から引き上げて、
そこに座って
、こんな感じで、初めて
このように髪を整えたときのように、
本当に何時だったかをチェックしたかったのです。 頭皮を引っ張っていたので頭を下に曲げることができなかった
ので、このようにここに座っ
ています。
ちょうど12時間後のようで、私はすでに元気だったよう
でしたうーん
ええ806。あなたはすでに知っています
ええごめんなさいええ6人の
ルームメイトのルームメイトああ誰か別のスーパーチャット
賢いメンズショー
カタカナで書かれたクールなヒラガナフーディーありがとう ええ
、それは
私が燃えているhaを持っている冗談です
漢字よりもカタカナが嫌いなので、漢字よりもカタカナが嫌い
です。漢字の場合は同じです。漢字の場合と同じです。
知っているか、
スキップしてかまいません。
あなたの人生を続けてくださいええ
、私
はそれを置くのに良い方法
であるこの種のスキットを持っていたように、そして私の学生と一緒にこの種のスキットは
カタカナ
を彼らに説明するようなものであり
、 そして、あなたは私に英語が正しいことを教えなければならないので、
私は大丈夫だったので
、テブルテーブルから始めましょう
。 ええ、
大丈夫、かっこいい、ベティ、
ベリー、
大丈夫、ええ、
ベランダ、
ええ、ビニール袋は、まさに
ビニールのようなものですが、大丈夫なので、AV
で始まる場合のように全体が得られます。
何か正しいものをバストする ええと
、私は
ソーダがあなたを群衆の中に投げ込み、あなた
が
熱狂的な良さで爆発するのを見ることができるようにあなたを振るつもりのようなものですええ私は
それが最も難しい部分と呼ばれたと思うことについてのビデオを持っていました
日本語のええええええええええ
私はそれを見たと思いますええええ
ええそれは普通の英語の単語を言おうとしているようなものでしたが
カリフォルニアのようなカタカナでは
それはひどい
です
ビーフィースーパーチャット本当にありがとうございます。
ビーフィー
ビーフィーは外国人が日本に入ることが
できます。私は彼らがええと思うかどうかはわかりません。
この時点でビジネスビザまたは学生ビザを持っている場合はあなたが
日本に入ることができます
私はそれが間違っていなければ観光客を除いてすべての人に開かれている
と思いますそれは2週間前のような最近の更新だったと思います
d in hindiも、
キャラクターが踊るのをやめないからです
ええ
ええそれ
はほんの少しでも読むのが簡単ではありません
ああねえクリスダーリンミュージックドーガン私は
あなたのピッチアクセントコースを取り、それを愛しています
あなたは素晴らしいですありがとうございます クリス
は、ジェイソンが
ソングライターの作曲家で
あり、ゲームスラッシュアニメのために何かアドバイスを書きたいと聞いて
とても
うれしく思います。
作曲家やソングライター
自身もこれを知っていると思いますが、
それを補強する
ために
、友達の作品
や存在する作品のように
見つけて、気分を盛り上げる自分の作品を作るのも好きです。
それは非常に重要なことだからです。 アニメ
のように、彼らが欲しいものや必要なもののムード
を持った曲を書くことができるのはご存知のようです。
もちろん
、オープニングのテーマソングと
その後、他の16曲の
ように、エピソードのバックグラウンド
でさまざまな時間に再生しますが、
ナルトのような何かが
おかしなことが起こっているとき
でも、バックグラウンドでそのようなものを持っている
ので、気分を設定できる必要があります それで
何か暗いことが起こっているならあなた
もそれを打つことができる必要があるので私は
ちょうど固体の悲しいピアノドットmp3のように言うでしょ
う m鹿
今、私の脳はいたるところにあり
ますそれは私が疲れている原因だと思います
ええ
昨夜は眠れなくなったよう
ですね外国人が
ケイゴを知って使うことは大したことです
めちゃくちゃになったら言いたく
ないけど外国人
ならもっと逃げられると思うけど
意図的にやらなくて
も遊べる
外国人の外人カードをちょっと
知らないのと同じように弾く あなた
が間違ったケーゲルのように使うなら、
それはもっと混乱するようなものになるかもしれません
私は実際に私
に尋ねました私はある日上司に尋ねました私は一種の彼に尋ね
ました 私はちょっと
すみません、私のケーキが本当に
そこにないので、私は学んでいます私は
それを上手くしようとしています彼は
心配しないで彼がそうであったようにsmosを使う
ようでした 重要なの
は、情報を入手できること
です。また、私は顧客
と一緒に仕事をしていないので、特に営業活動を
行っていないので、
別の強力なものを持っていることは重要ではありません。
コスプレはどうしたの？
ライブストリームで、あなたはあなたの前にデイブトリッピンについて聞いたことがありますか
こんにちは、
ごめんなさい
、このええと、だましの
ようなものは何ですか？
少し前のビデオは、動揺しないように、
または
日本のヒントやコツ
がわからないようでした。見た目がわからないときは、正しいケイゴを
オンラインで調べてください。それが
日本人のことです。 とにかく10回のうち9回やってください
ええあなたが
グーグルに行ってあなたがケゲルを知っているようにタイプすることを
知っ
ているなら お互い
にどうやってこれをやるのか正確
にどの時点で使う
のかええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 人々は
あなたがとても幸運であるようにそう
そういや nglishにはkeigoがありません私はそうです
それはただ違う言語ではありませんそれは
あなたがすでに持っている言葉を
どのように使うかです
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 顧客やその他の
関係、
またはあなたが
私のためにこれを行うことができるか、あなたが私のために
これを行うか、またはこれが
すべて同じものであるかのようにいつ行われるかを知っていますが、それら
はええええええええええと 正直
なところ、これは私の言う状況の認識と同じかもしれないとは思いません
が
、日本語や日本で使われる外来語が
増えるにつれて、一種の緊迫感がより
自然になって
いるように思えます。
そのようなものを取り巻く職場や社会のような区別の役割の区別のようにそれをどのように呼んでいますか
ええそれは正直なところ私の印象ではありません
そしてそれは面白いです私はかなりの数を持っています
日本のバイリンガルの友達のような日本人の
友達と
は何か、そして彼らの中にはあなたが半分日本人の半分を知っているような人もいます
が、彼らの中には英語を学ぶだけの完全な日本人
もいます。 そうそうそうそうそうそう
言語は私が東京に住んでいる強力なものです
彼は日本のユーチューバーですあなたは
私の悪い人を殺さなけれ
ばなりません私はその勝利者に謝罪
します
大学の教授の一人から聞いた話でし
たが、実は
50年前のよう
に東京に留学した私の教授のように
、彼が日本の大学に通っていた50年前のような話でした。  2人の教授は
1人はもう1人より年上でしたが
、若い方は大学内でより高い地位にあった
か
、古い方と同じように大学に長く在籍していたようでした。
転校した
ので、彼はその大学のサム・コールハイトのようでした
が、年齢的には先輩
でした。教師は実際にはお互い
に英語で話すことを好んだ
ので、
そうする必要はなかったと彼は
言いました。
ええ
、これも
私の人のように全体に似ているような気がします。日本語を
話すときに性格が変わるとは言い
たくないのですが
、日本語で出てくるマナーはそうではありません。
英語で出てき
ますええそれは確かに本当だと思いますそうですそしてそれ
はあなたの脳が部分的にちょうど一種のように
あなたが知っているような特定のもののように
トピックですが、
先日、棒や石全体
が骨を折る可能性があると思っていましたが、それは私を傷つけることではありませんでした
が、言葉に
は意図があるようですええ
言葉はまさに怖いものです
ええと、
空手キッドのよう
に、私が初めて髪を編んだときは、みんなが
オハイオ州の
よう
でした。
私は特に日本でいくつかを持っているという意味で呼ばれています
人々は
ああエディマーフィのようになります私はええとええ
私たちは両方とも黒です
ええそれはそれの終わりについてですええ
ええええ あなたの名前はケビンです
ええそれは彼がハリウッド俳優
のように私より50歳年上である唯一の類似点
です私は彼らが有名な人ですええ
日本からこんにちは日本
から日本へこんにちは
私は
髪の三つ編みを手に入れられなかったのでとてもうれしいです覚えています
私は間違いなくここで自分自身と付き合っていますが
、有名なジェットジャクソンと呼ばれるディズニーと呼ばれるテレビ番組がありました
当時、私もアフロの権利を持っていなかった
ので、彼は要点を述べました。 さて
、私は子供たちが
店で私に
近づいてきて、あなたが有名なジャクソンのように見えるところまで彼らのように見えましたええ、私
はあなたです
が、私のお気に入りは私がトラックにいたようでした
会って
嘘をつくつもりはないこの
2人のかわいい女の子が、
三段跳びなどをしているときに
棒高跳びのようにやり過ぎ
ていたのです。 まるでフィールドを疾走しないように走っているのを知っている
ので、彼らはそうですが
、私の地域にはたくさんの人がいるので、
彼らが
ここに来ているのか、彼らが走っているものは何でもそうは思いません
このように私にまっすぐに向かっている
ように
、有名な
ジェド・ジャクソン
がここまで走っていて、面白いと言ってくれたと誰かが
言ったようです。
実際にはそれほど多くは見えません。
彼はもっと丸いものを持っていたように感じ
ます私の顔はもっと楕円形になり
ました多分大丈夫
私はこれをたくさんやっただけで、
最終的にはもっと顔を丸めました
が、ええ、子供の頃は彼女の顔の周りにたくさん
ありました。ドーガンとジェイソン私はあなたのアドバイスが必要です
私のガールフレンドは100人の日本人で
、神奈川に住ん
でいます
2020年1月からパンデミックで一緒に
いましたあなたは日本にいませんあなたは日本にいないので
私の日本語は
今のところn4に近いと
思い
ます 私は壊れた中で彼女と話し
ます私はそう言います私は何度も表現を台無しにするのでええと言い
ます
彼女のボーイフレンドええと、私はそうだと思います。
少なくとも努力するほうがいい
と思い
ます。あなたが日本語を学ぶ努力をしていることを彼女は喜んでくれると思います
が、同時に
あなたはそうする必要はありません。
あなたが彼女と話しているときだけその努力をしてください
私の一番の
アドバイスは日本語を勉強することです
彼女と一緒にいるときは彼女が
それほど修正する必要がないように
、そしてあなたが彼女と一緒にいるときは日本語と英語の組み合わせを使うことができるように、できるだけ多くの
アネセをしてからできるだけ進歩させてください そして同時に
私はあなたがデートしているならあなたが知っている
ように私が意味するのであれば私は
彼女が私ができるのと
同じようにあなたに我慢してくれることを彼女が喜んで喜んでくれることを願っています
何度も何度も私の質問で誰か
を悩ませます
私はそれが私のように正しいことを願っていますええええええ
あなたがベッドに戻って会うのはまさに素晴らしいですがジェイソン
はあなたがそこであなたの時間を楽しんでくれることを願っています
私は
もう1年以上彼女に会っていません
、そして
同じような状況にある他の人に私はあなた
が面白いと感じます私はこれを言うのが嫌い
です 世界です
が、基本的にwiを始めるための隠士であるyoutuberとして
すでに結婚して
いて
、コロナの事が始まっていないことを知っている前から誰か
と一緒に住んでいて、別府のような小さな街に住んでいるの
は、私にとってはあまり変わってい
ません。
あなたは外にいて、
混雑しすぎた場所に入らないようにしますが
、別府の混雑しすぎた場所は
、そこに5人いる
場合のようですええ、確かにそうで
はありません。
また、私は誰かを見ました私は以前に
誰かを見ましたええと
、彼らは
ジェットジャクソンよりもよく見える
と言ってい
ました私は私の有料俳優がうまくやっていると言うでしょう
私を美しく見せるためのあなたのチャット
あなたはレイズを取得しますそれについて心配しないでください
ちょっと
私はそれが彼が別の目を持っていたようだと思います
ただ  当時、私の目
は文字通り黒く塗ったように焼かれていました。
なぜなら、光が
右のピザパイのように私の目に当たらない限り
、私の
目
が何年にもわたって色があったことを非常に具体的に見分けられない限り、
明るくなりましたが
、
これは私が持っていたものと比較して軽い
ようですうーん私はそれがあなた
よりも一般的に暗い顔色を持って
いたように感じます
私は屋外で大丈夫だったので大丈夫だと
思いますがそうですがそうです古い写真を並べ
て見たときの写真が見えないようなものでした
でも
それを並べてみると、
幻想が壊れているのを知っている
ようなものですええ
、彼の名前はマルーン5の男で
、メインシンガーの
アダム・レヴィーンは彼の名前だと思います。
私は彼を覚えているので私はより多くの髪を大丈夫でした
彼が
2000年代初頭に髪の毛を真っ直ぐにスウッシュした
としたら、私は高校でバズカットをしたようなものを手に入れていまし
た。
こういう時は
具体的には
ある種の表情みたい
な感じでねええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
早すぎる出力
には賛否両論があります。明らかに賛否両論は、
自分自身を明確に表現し、
さまざまな種類の井戸を
構築して、さまざまなボーカブや文法ポイントのようなものを構築することを知っているときに、そのような余分な種類の練習をすることです。
最終的にそれらを組み合わせる方法を学んだが
、同時に、早すぎる話をしようとすると、
悪い習慣
を身につける
可能性があります。 このような
ことを知っているように、
それは良いスタートのように聞こえるという点
でひどく間違っているわけではありません少なくともジェイソン東京で警官を買うことによって人種プロファイリング警官にどのように対処し
ますか
福岡ではおかしいです。
実際に東京にいるのかわからないのですが
、スーパーチャットは
ありがとうございました。
青い月に一度
、朝の10時
くらい
まで六本木を手放すのが好きなら、彼らはあなた
がまだここにいるジンの一人のようになるので
、あなたの ものですが、一般的に
言って、
私はそれがどのようなものかわかりません私はちょうど私
は本当に
好きではあり
ませんそして私は好きではありません私は好きではありませ
ん あなたは
次のスーパーチャットに行きますが、そのように私は後で言いたいことを思い出させます
大丈夫ええ私はいつも聞いています ああ、私は
ハブで洗い流された外人になりたくありません
が、
彼らは実際においしい食べ物と飲み物を
持っていますか？彼らはすべて好きなメニューアイテムを持っていません私は
個人的に私が実際に良いハブサイダーとラムカボブを楽しんでいます
実は
、クリス・ブロードと一緒に一度行ったらハブに行ったことが
あると思い
ますええ、ガイジンバーに行ったのは初めてだったと思いますええ、
このあたりのハブではないので、私
は思いません 彼らは
ええと、私はカップルに行ったことがありますが、私は
2倍貧しい
ので、私はそこに行かないようなことが多いので
、スーパーチャットにも感謝します ちなみに、
それは大きなものだと本当に感謝して
います。ベッドの上で光沢があります。
そうそう、それは別
の分厚いものです。 時々私は
自分のお金のために自分の強打を心配しているようなものな
ので、私が飲み物を手に入れたら、
それは水を切ることができない
ので、nのように確認します o
カクテルええと、
私が必死になったらそこで食べ物を手に入れるかもしれません
が、そうでなけれ
ば、基本
的にそこにあるすべてのもののようにプレミアムを支払う必要があります。
私は家にいるのが好きで、
水を飲むのが
好きなので、お金を節約するのが好きです。ええと
、余分な袖を正しく手に入れて
ください。
多くの人と私は
誰も知ら
ないのでiii私は決して
あなたの投票ではありませんええそれは私のことではあり
ませんええとあなたは本当の質問方言を知っていますか
ああ、
それは人種プロファイリングでしたええ、
そうそう、ええと、ええ、本当に速い私は
ちょうどそれが面白いと思ったの
です。 ええ多分だ
から私はただ待って
大丈夫です
ええ
とあなたは何を言いますか ああ、
そういうわけで、ある状況で日本語がわからないと
思ってしまう
ところがあります。うーん、初めて日本に来たときは、自然と日本語を
少し知っていたのですが、
どこかに行ってみたら、
えーと
このスピーカー
でスーパーキックのようなケイゴのように、私の心の中で私は
これを手で運ぶことができると思います
私はバッグが必要
ですか？ いいえいいえ私はあなたが言ったことを理解し
ます私は自分自身にちょうど
バッグが必要だ
と思ってい
ますか ああ、彼は
私が自分自身をどのように運ぶのかわからない
ことを理解していませんでした。
ええと、
日本の友達が店にいて
、誰かに
聞いてみたら 店員のように店に
行くと、彼らは大丈夫かっこいいので、
戻ってき
て、日本人の友達にすべての情報を教えてくれ
ます。 返事をしますが、
今はもう起こりません。
シフトがどこにあったのかわからないような
ものです。この面白い話
の中で、最近
私にも起こり始めている詐欺だと思うので、
明らかに私の職業では、私は
日本語ではありませんが、
基本的にどんな状況でも私にとっては問題ではありません
が、それ
に
もかかわらず、私は過去にほとんどの状況で問題を抱えていませんでしたが、一般的に言えば私はしませ
ん」
留学が終わってからはほとんど苦労しなかったので、5年から本当に現実的には10年も知っ
ていますが、
留学中のように早くから
東京で女の子とほぼ毎回付き合っていました。
多分それはあなたが若いから
だ d彼らはああ、
この人はおそらく最近日本に来たと思い
ます。なぜなら、通常は日本で生まれ育ったわけではないからです。
そう、
これはおそらく若いカップルのよう
です。
多くの場合、私が妻と一緒にいる場合でも、
彼らは私に話しかけ、そうだと言うでしょう。
そうだと思います。おそらく
年齢の組み合わせであり、おそらく
もっと多くの人々が外国人
との交流や取引に慣れているのだと思います。
もっとええ、それはおそらくそれの一部でもありますそれはおそらく
観光客の不足のため
ですえ
えとええと、世界がゾンビアルファに行く前にこの変化が起こったと感じた
のでええええええええええええ私もそう
です もちろん
気づかなかったので指を入れ
てすぐに気づかなかったのはしばらくして
からのよう
でした今日はバッグが必要かどうか決めるのに本当に長い時間がかかり
ました ええと、それはlでした
私は自分の電話で何かをしているようなもので、
これを部分的に覚え
ているので、私は自分の電話でこれをやっていたのです。
バッグなので
、私は彼らが私に手渡そうとしているものがどれほど暑いのかを考えようとして
います。
その熱でそれを手で強くすることができますか、
それともバッグに入れたいの
ですか？ 私の指紋を保存し
、ミブとええとに参加しないでください、
そしてそれは私がそれについて考えるのに8-9秒のように簡単にかかったよう
ですそして彼女は私を邪魔しませんでした彼女は
ちょうど
誰かが言ったよう
なものでし
た 今の
コンビニでは、コンビニエンスストアで働く外国人がかなりいるように、それもそうかもしれないと思いますが
、コンビニエンス
だけでなく
、グローバルなもののよう
です。
私はそれが理にかなっていることを意味します
でも、秋葉原のどこか、いい友達のために北海道に行ったときのような場所を知っているように、基本的に日本人だけがスタッフを務めるアニメイトが好きになりました。
結婚式それは
あなたが知っているように私は間違いなく
私がそこで見た2人半の外国人の一人の
よう
でしたそしてええと私はそうだった 日本での時間など
を聞かれるように、空には誰もいないようなものでした。
それがターニング
ポイントだったのかもしれませ
ん。 日本に
いたら
知ってるよねええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
今が
暴言をやめようとする時です
ええと、
オリンピックが少し助けになったかもしれないのを見てみましょ
うええと、少しドーガン2つの小さなドガン
私は双子を持っているので、ジェイソン
私は
プランナー
です
私の場合、私は
動き
のようなものや動きのあるもののようなものにもっと焦点を当てているので、基本
的にはこのキャラクターがこのようにジャンプするのは大丈夫のようです
賢明なようにバランスをとる必要がある場合や、テキストに対して設定する必要がある場合や、
適切な字幕などを実装
する必要がある場合など、ゲームの
日本語で漢字の最初の漢字を学んでいる
ときに出会った
[音楽]
人体の体温に暖かい酒です
そうそうそうそう ite
日本語の単語は
英語で私のお気に入りの英語の単語と同じ
ですデ
フェネストレーションデフェネストレーション
ええそれが誰かまたは何かを窓から投げることであるということを知らない人のためにええええ
特に
窓そして
あなたが その人をやる
のは良い答えなので
、その素晴らしい答えにつながったスーパーチャットに感謝します
あなたたちはどのように通過し
たのですか？
この時点
で、日本語のローンの単語がどれほど似ているかという理由で、この段階に
到達したとしたら、明日のようにこの単語が実際の間に単独の単語に置き換えられるのに、なぜこれらのカンジを学んでいるのかということです。
より多くの学習段階
のようなものです私
はえええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ  やる気を維持し
、いつ休憩を取るかを知っ
てください。パワースルーを試してみると、
バックファイアが発生することがよくあり
ます。これは
燃え尽き症候群です。
いつ休憩する
かを知っておく必要がありますジェイソンが犬と友達であるとは知りませんでし
た。動物園の会議室で仕事のために一度だけあなたを見たので、あなたがストリームにいるのを見てうれしい
です。 私の
ゲームデザインへの進出
は非常に幸運でし
た。少なくとも趣味として学ぶことは
絶対に可能だと思います
が、私の母
はそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそのためのコンサートを覚えていません
ええと、彼ら
は彼女の名前のためにかんじを入力しましたああ、それがko
kakidotaだったら私はそれを読むことができたでしょうが
、
ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、私
はそれが何をしていたのですか？
。
私はちょっと私がしたいようでした私は私が
ビデオゲーム
と私のmを作りたいと思います まっすぐ上に行っ
た彼女は私にモーフィアスをしました
彼女は私
たちがバーンズに行ったように私に見せてくれました高貴な彼女は
彼女が私にゲームデザインの本を買ってくれました
ええ、あなたがこれについて真剣に考え
ているなら、あなたが得たものを見せてください
、そしてそれは私が
好きなものを知っていることを学び始めたところですが、もっと
重要なの
は、もちろん子供の頃、私は
プログラムしたいと思っていたので、ゲームデザインで好きではなかったものです ビデオゲーム私
はジャックプログラミングをプログラムしたくないのです
が、それは本当かブリックになります。コンピュータサイエンス専攻
はもうやりたくないので、
それをたくさんやりました。 趣味として、あなた
はちょうど一種のピックアップの
ようなものを知っています、そしてあなたはそれが趣味としてそれを拾うことができる
ようなものは何でも好きなようにひねりのようなもの
です
私がゲームデザインに入る前の先生は、
そうそうベック なぜなら、私は
最初に日本に来たとき
は学生だったので、学生として日本に来たので
、学校でお金を稼ぐためだけにパートタイムの英語教育をし
ましたが、卒業したときに私の会社に就職しまし
た。 特に会社に
行くと、あなたは
いくつかのつながりが好きになったと言っていたので、私
たちは
死んだトーナメントや生きているトーナメントのような発表の仕事をし
ていました。
m決してトップのライバル
とは違いますが、私は競争力のあるプレー
をしていて、実際には締め切り5のファンイベントの1つに行きました
。
ゲーム
で、あることが別のことにつながり、
実際
にそのトーナメントの英語の解説をすることになりました。
これは、2005年の
ことだったと思います。
その中に私も
その李を示した ke
私はシステムについて多くのことを知っていました、
そしてそれは本当に重要でした。なぜなら、
私がゲームのバランスをとるのを手伝うつもりなら、私は
詳細なシステムのように知る必要があり、
彼らは彼らが教えたかもしれないことをあなたに知ってもらうことができた
からです ゼロからの誰かですが、
70％のように誰かに教える
ことができれば、彼らは
大丈夫だと思います
ので、日本で成功し、
幸せな充実した生活を送っている多くの人々のために私は同意します 長期的には、
多くの場合
、あなたのスキルがすべて揃っ
て
しまうので、そのようなこと
があなたと私と一緒に起こったように聞こえます。私と
同じように、私はトリックからビデオ編集を行う方法を学びました。
私はyoutuberなので、仕事のために編集しているのは明らかです。私は
大学から日本語
を学び、自分で勉強することから日本語を学びました。その後
、ジェットプログラムの自由時間に、ほとんど自分でクリエイティブなライティングを学びました。
これら3つすべてが必要です。 スキル
私がYouTubeでやっていることをやって
みてください。あなたは
、トリックや
武道、人間の観察
や運動感覚
などのスキルを身に付け、非常に高いレベルで日本語を使って日本で競争力のある学校に通い、
死んでいるか生きているかのような経験をしているよう
です。
それらのすべては、それらの1つ
だけでプラスプラスプラス
のように
なるのではなく、それぞれの中でのようになります。
それは、私が自分自身についてどのように感じているかのよう
です。
チェスのゲームのような生活で、
チェックメイトを1人だけ設定することはありません。
計画がうまくいくなら素晴らしいですが、計画abとcが
絶対にあなたがボートの火に降りることを知っているなら
、私はまだdとeを少なくとも
正しくしました
、そしてそうです、そしてあなたが言っ
たように
それは私が多くの道のようです ある種の仕事をして、
それから見よ それらはすべて一種の
うんええ星は一種の整列
ええええしかしそれはあなたがあなたが
何をしたいのか正確にわからなくてもあなたが追加で何をしたいのかわからなくてもあなたが側であなたのスキルを開発し続けなければならない理由です
スキル
は
、将来
、それがどうなるかをもう一度知っているかどうかに関係なく、それを使って
何かをすることができるようになる可能性がはるかに高くなりますが、
残念ながら、私たちは
今のようになりました 学校から女の子を迎えに
行くええと、もう1つ質問に答えること
ができます。人生の情熱を決めてから、成功するまでにどれくらいの時間がかかり
ましたか。
落とし穴のトンたくさんの落とし穴ヘラの
落とし穴ええヘラの落とし穴私は
それ
がすべての星が整列しているようなものだと思います
そして私の場合も
おそらくあなたも
星が整列した後も
あなたがちょうどええと好きになるようなものです わぁ
レースのスタート地点
のよう
に言うの
ですかええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ YouTubeを始めたいと思っている人は、
コンテンツの粘り強さを出し続ける必要があります。ええ、正確
に正確にそうです。
いくつかの質問に答えることができれば幸いです。感謝祭のストリームで
私とジェイソンを楽しんでいただければ幸い
です。 コメントとスーパーチャット、そして
入って来たすべてのサポート、そして
残念ながら
今回は別のビデオ
を作ることができませんでしたが、比較的近い将来に別のビデオを作ることができるといいのですが
かなりメジャー
な更新が
あります。これ
については、6か月ほどで少し前に話しましたが、
ジェイソンは
あちこちにいると思い
ます。
ええ、大丈夫です。とにかく、また来てくれたみんな
に感謝します。
そして、すべてのサポートに感謝します。幸せな感謝祭と
私はまたすぐにみんなと話します。